come now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week no matter
where people work there's always the
possibility of a health emergency
suddenly occurring but how prepared are
we to handle it
two new surveys commissioned by the
American Heart Association looked at the
issue one asked employees from multiple
fields about their level of first aid
and CPR training more than 85 percent
thought that this type of training is
important to keep the work environment
safe
however 33 percent said they never
received such training from a work
environment or any other source CBS News
contributor dr. taryn Rula is here to
tell us more about the survey Tara good
morning morning Dana so multiple
industries when they were looking at
this training what did the results show
so this is so important because one of
the worst things you can feel is that
helpless sense that somebody is down and
I don't know what to do and in fact
there are about 10,000 cardiovascular
arrests that occur every year in the
workplace so this is really a big gap
that can be filled by employers to
improve workplace safety CPR can attend
double or triple survival rates when
done effectively so when they looked
across industries what they found is
that there were big variations so
education 63% of the workers in
education said that they got training
from their current employer that is
opposed to about 19% for instance in the
hospitality or service industry so again
big variations and also 55% of those who
said they got trained it was not from
their current employer so a lot of room
for improvement if employers offer
training the the survey show that
employees actually want that training
they do want it overwhelmingly the
majority over 90 percent in this survey
said they would want the training they
felt it would improve their ability to
deal with an emergency and not many of
them expressed hesitation about getting
training about 46 percent said they
would have no hesitation and if there
were those that did express hesitation
it was because they would have to either
come to work early or leave late or
maybe they felt uncomfortable practicing
in front of colleagues or had lack of
management's yeah along those lines was
there a certain way that they wanted to
get it online or in person anything like
that you would think maybe online
because that's easier but in fact the
majority wanted to get it in person
hands-on in a classroom typesetting what
are the other things the survey found is
that employees said that if their if
their jobs offered this that they would
feel like they trusted their employer
more they would feel more positive about
their employer and more likely to stay
with them longer so you know this is
really a great opportunity for employers
because what you don't want and what
usually happens is something happens
that's bad and somebody dies or suffers
a cardiac arrest and then suddenly the
change happens in the workplace be
proactive instead of reactive we move on
to our next topic which is childhood
obesity according to the Centers for
Disease Control from 2011 to 2014 around
17% of children and adolescents aged 2
to 19 were considered obese that equates
to about 12 point 7 million children
nationwide this week the US Preventive
Services Task Force released its updated
recommendations on screening children
for obesity Tara what did the force
recommend so the recommendations are
similar to those in 2010 and that is
that children 6 or older should be
screened for obesity and if they're
found to be obese then their doctor
should refer them for comprehensive
intensive behavioral interventions and
that's been shown to help improve the
maintenance of weight loss if they get
over 26 hours over the course of 2 to 12
months and it's so important because we
know that about 80% of those children
who are obese will go on to become obese
adults they're at risk for depression
sleep apnea asthma cardiovascular risk
factors teasing bullying very important
I live this so I know this very well
when you talk about those interventions
what does that mean what does that
encompass so they talked about targeting
the child alone or the parents alone or
both together talked about supervised
physical activity sessions educating
them on nutrition and diet reading food
labels which I do with my five-year-old
daughter she knows how to read the label
and really teaching them about limits
limiting screen time limiting access to
tempting foods and goal-setting so you
know kids are really sponges they want
to learn they can learn and there's no
reason we shouldn't be targeting them
this is one of the best tools and skills
we can give our kids it will help them
for the rest of their life
no doubt about it finally we're going to
walk into the future years from now if
you ever need help getting around it
could be from the form of an exoskeleton
research published in the journal
science shows the development of a
personalized exoskeleton system it can
adapt to the way you walk even helping
to minimize the energy your body spends
it was a small trial but results showed
wearing this exoskeleton on just one
ankle reduced average energy expenditure
by about 24% they open the future this
technology can help improve the mobility
for a range of people from those
suffering from strokes to injured
athletes this is really remarkable yeah
so it's not just about creating a bionic
human but it's really about helping
those who've had injuries or accidents
and with the nice thing about this one
is that they tailored it to the person
so some of these exoskeletons if they're
not individualized they actually can
cause you to to increase your energy
expenditure but this one because it
works with your body actually decreases
the amount of energy you're expending
great information dr. taryn Rula thank
you